[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام
هل يعقل ان الزعيم النازيه شهير ادولف
هتلر امر قواته بعدم استخدام السلاح
الكيماوي ضد الاعداء بينما استخدمه بشار
الاسد ضد شعبه يصيح معارض سوري
لماذا مازال النظام السوري في استخدام
اسلحه الدمار الشامل مع العلم ان كل الدول
الكبرى تؤكد ذلك
اليس من السقف اتهام الثوار هل يعقل ان
يستخدم الثوار السلاح الكيماوي ضد المناطق
التي يسيطرون عليها في الغوطه وضد البيئه
الشعبيه التي تحتضنهم الم يكن من الاجدر
استخدامها في القصير مثلا ضد قوات النظام
وحزب الله التي اخرجتهم منها مجنون يحكي
وعاقل يسمع
اليست العقليه الحاكمه في سوريا مستعده ان
تستخدم النووي لو توفر لديها للبقاء في
السلطه اليس استخدام الكيماوي ضد المدنيين
هو استكمال مفضوح لشعار النظام الاسد او
نحرق البلد
الم يحتفل المؤيدون نظام ووزعوا الحلوى
احتفالا في ضرب الغوطه بالكيماوي
لكن في المقابل
الم يتحدى وزير الخارجيه السوريه اليوم اي
جهه في العالم ان تثبت ان نظامه استخدم
الكيماويه فعلا الم يصف الرئيس السوري
الاتهامات الغربيه له باستخدام الكيماوي
بانها خارج العقل والمنطق من يستخدم اسلحه
دمار شامل ضد شعبه يتساءل وليد المعلم
اليس من الممكن ان يكون الطرف الاخر قد
استخدم الكيماويه لتوريط النظام كي يتعرض
لضربه عسكريه دوليه
لماذا يحاول البعض تكذيب الحكومه السوريه
واتهامها بانها لم تصدق يوما حتى في درجات
الحراره الم يكذب ضربوا ذات يوم ايضا بشان
اسلحه الدمار الشامل العراقيه المزعومه
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على
المعارضه السوري بسام جعاره وعلى الناشط
المؤيد حيثما سباحه نبدا النقاش بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس لو بدات معك طبول الحرب تقرع في
المنطقه ردا علي الكيماوي السوري في الان
ذاته
القياده السوريه ممثله بالرئيس الاسد
وبوزير الخارجيه
تؤكد انها لم تستخدم الكيماوي اين تذهب
الامور دكتور اسمح لي راح في في لندن اه
شعبنا الصامد والله ساعه مصر اقتربت قبل
ان ادخل في الاجابه اللي اعتراض على من
ضمن كلامك انت قلت انه بشار يقتل شعبه
ومتهم بقدر شابه الشعب السوري ليس شعب شعب
بشار هم اولئك المرتزقه هم اولئك الشبيحه
الذين يقتلون الناس من سنتين ونصف لا يوجد
لا يوجد احد في العالم يمكن ان يرتكب هذه
الجرائم بحق شعبه ولا بحق اعدائها ايضا
ثانيا اعتراض اخر يعني هناك كلام هل هناك
عاقل يقتل شعبه من قال لك ان هذا المعتوه
عاقل لا يقدم على هذه الافعال الاجراميه
الى رجل معتوه ومريض وعندنا كل الادله
التي تؤكد ان هذا الرجل يحتاج الى علاج
واختار واخشى ان اكمل هذا الموضوع يمكن ان
ينفذ من الجرائم التي ارتكبها لان اي لجنه
طبيه ستقول ان هذا الشخص معترض يقتل الناس
من سنتين مصر ويجب ويتبعها في مجالسه
الخاصه انه كاذب هذا اولا ثانيا اسمح لي
ضربه الوسطين ليست الطلب الاولى هاي الرقم
اثنين وستين ثمانيه واربعين ضربه في دمشق
وستين ضربه بسوريا وتحديد جدول يوضح
معلومات انا عاوز معلومات ما هي المعلومات
ثمانيه واربعين ضربه في في دمشق وريفها
ثمانيه واربعين ثمانيه واربعين
المصادر
جمعيات حقوقيه
وموثق بالساعه بالتاريخ ونوع الغاز ونوعا
سلاح وعدد القتلى وعندنا اسماء القتلى
واسبان المصابين ونستطيع ان نعطي هذه
المعلومات لاي جهه في العالم هذا اولا
نسبه اصابه المدنيين بهجمات كيماوي سبعه
وتسعين بالمائه خمسه بالمائه وسبعه وتسعين
مدنيه
بكل اسف لن نظيف معلومه ثلاثين فلسطيني
قتلوا بالكيماوي ولاول مره من عام ثمانيه
واربعين من عام الف وتسع مائه فلسطيني
بالكيماوي هذا الذي يتحدث مثل الممانعه
والمقاومه قتل في غوطه دمشق في هذه الضربه
ثلاثين فلسطيني وعندنا اسمائهم خمسه
وثمانين بالمائه ستخسر
هذا الرجل خمسه وثمانين يعني
خمسه وثمانين بالمائه من الهجمات
الامر اختلف امس بعد كل ما جرى طلب الكبرى
عند خان العسل بحلب استخدم الفوسفور
الابيض من شهداء خمسين مصاب موجودين وعلى
اللجنه ان تذهب
ثانيا الضربه وقعت وكنا فجرا مع القطع
الاسكان و نسمع اصوات القذائف واستمر
النظام بعد كل ما جرى بقصف الناس بعض
الكيماوي استمر بقصف الناس وكانت هناك
دبابات في موقعين ان تسوق ال السلطاني وفي
ساحه العباسيين واضطر الجيش الحر الى
التعامل معهم من منطقه التجاره كان من
المخطط بعد ساعات من ضرب الكيماوي عندما
تكون الاثار السري ان يدخل الجيش جيش
الشبيحه جيش بشار وان يجتاح الغوطه هم
يعرفون تماما ان الغوطه اسمح لي بس
باختصار الماضي خمسطاشر الخمسطاش دمشق
دمشق شو كيف في حاله بشار الاسد
ما هي سمعت هذا الكلام يعني في الوقت الذي
نسمع فيه القياده السوريه تنفي نفيا قاطعا
نعود الى ما كانت تقوله القياده السوريه
في الماضي مثلا وزير الخارجيه
السوري النفي اليوم نفى ان يكون قد
استخدموا الكيماوي ولكننا سمعنا نفس
الكلام من وليد المعلم ب 2011 عندما قال
لا يمكن للجيش ان يطلق الرصاص على شعبه
عام 2012 قال المعلم لا يمكن للجيش ان
يقصف شعبه بالطائرات والان يقول لا يمكن
للجيش ان يقصف شعبه بالكيماوي المسلسل
واضح يعني الضرب الكيماوي اصلا هناك من
يقول ان من يشكك ب استخدام النظام السوري
للكيماوي كما يشكك من يقول ان الشمس لا
تشرق من الشرق كيف كيف ترد عليهم
اولا يعني بالنسبه الي انا اعتبرها على
جميع الاطفال والنساء الذين قتلوا في
الغوطه الشرقيه او الغربيه في في هذه
العمليه يوم الاربعه بالضبط لماذا لم تعلن
الحداد عليهم
كل شخص يعلن اعلنت الحداد عليه الف
وخمسمائه واحد تتلوى النظام ليس متورطا
لماذا لم يعلن الحداد
الحداد سيؤدي الى وقف اي عمليه تحقيق
اولا يعني اريد ان نرد على
اذا كان عندك هذه المعطيات كلها وصلنا
الامم المتحده سلمها ل ل ل اه بان كي مون
لجون كيري او لدى
ممكن ساعدت كثير في في تغطيه هذه القضيه
يعني حاليا ا في ورطه في ورطه بتجهيز
بتجهيز اه الضربه الى سوريا وكلام من هذا
النحو ونحن نعرف نعطيهم هذه المعلومات
وستين ضربه كيماويه فهو سيستفيد منها يعني
يستفيدوا منها ممكن يسالك ومن قال لك ومن
قال لك انت تعلم سيد اسمعي وانتعاش تعيش
في الغرب
اوباما اكدت برده اكد الضربه استراليا
اكدت الضربه حتى ايران وروسيا ايران
وروسيا الى الرئيس الايراني الرئيس
الايراني صاحب طالب الامس السلاح الكيماوي
واستخدم في سوريا هناك نوع اه سلاح كيماوي
غزه استخدم في هذه المنطقه نعم استخدم لكن
المشكله هنا استخدم من طرف منعها هذه هذه
القصه الموجوده يعني لناخذ المعطيات على
جميع الاراضي السوريه اولا الجيش العربي
السوري يتقدم في عده مناطق تقدم في القصير
تقدم في حمص الخالديه يتقدم في الغوطه
الشرقيه يتقدم في الخط ان الغربيه اعلن عن
عمليه درع العاصمه في في دمشق هذه
المجموعات وهناك في جهات
وتصاريح
لمقاتلين من هذه المجموعات انه لا يوجد
احد يساعدهم لا يرسل السلاح هناك يعني هم
محصورين في وضع خانق لا ياتيهم اي شيء
وبعضهم يعني نشر الغسيل على سليم بليس
وغيرها
الموضوع هنا ان ال ال الجيش العربي السوري
يريد الدخول اذا الى هذه المناطق لتامين
دمشق لتامين المنطقه حوالين دمشق
فعند وصول
في هناك معطيات دكتور عند وصول هؤلاء
المحققين الثلاثه هذا الجيش السوري عده
مناطق المحققين الدوليين مسؤوليتهم في في
مناطق اخرى
بدا الهجوم صباحا
فاطلق فاطلق دعني اقول اه سلاح لا نعرف من
اين اتى لكن كل ما رايناه ان اطفال
موجودين هؤلاء الاطفال ليس لهم اهالي اين
اهلهم هؤلاء الاطفال
اتوا بهم الى الى الى هذه المناطق دعني
اقول شيءا عندما تسال ام
كيف
الحقيقه يعني هاي الامه هاي الطفل
هذه صوره واحده من
هذا الرضيع هذا
دقيقه
سؤال يعني وصل هذا السؤال كثير والشرع
يساله يعني الناس تسخر من الادعاءات التي
تقول ان الثوار او الارهابيين اللي بدنا
نسميه وانت يستخدمون السلاح ضد انفسهم
السؤال المطروح يعني
هل يعقل ان هؤلاء الثوار السوريين دمروا
المدن فوق رؤوس انفسهم هل يعقل انهم قاموا
بالكثير من المجازر ده انفسهم وضد اهلهم
هل يعقل انهم يستخدمون السلاح الكيماوي ضد
انفسهم يعني ما بعمري
او ثوار سوريا والشيء الاخر طيب نحن نعلم
ان الثوار السوريين يسيطرون على الغوطه
وهي تحتضنهم شعبيا وكل ذلك هل يعقل ان
يطلق الكيماوي على الناس اللي بيحب هن
كانوا ممكن يطبقوها على القصير عندما
هزموا في القصير مجنون يحكي وعاقل يسمع
هناك كتاب ونحن نعرف جميعا والعالم كله
يعني ان هناك كتائب لها مصالح تختلف عن
الكتائب
يعني ما مصلحه الدوله في سوريا ان تطلق ال
ال القضاء اذا قالوا انا لا ادري اذا
موجود كيماوي في سوريا انا لست العسكريه
يعني اه ان وجود تطلقه امام المحققين على
بعض
وهناك نقطه لن يشرحها احد هل الدوله في
سوريا والقياده في سوريا والسياسه في
سوريا تستطيع او يعني عملا استفزازيا
توقع
مؤيديها من روسيا والصين
في هذا تحرجهم يعني هذا هذا سؤال ايضا في
منطقه الرجل يقول لك طيب يعني سؤال ايضا
يتبادر الى الذهن هل يعقل ان هذا النظام
الى درجه انه يطلق الكيماوي والمفتشون
موجودون هل يعني اه وليد المعلم اليوم قال
قال نحن طلبنا من الامم المتحده منذ اشهر
بان ترسل لنا محققين ومفتشين لكن الامم
المتحده لم ترسل طيب هل يعقل ان يسمع هذا
النظام ب دخول المفتشين الى المعظميه والى
الغوطه الشرقيه
لو كان لديه شيء ايضا كمان عقليه يحكي
المجموعه
اه هو مانو عسكري ما بيعرف بس اكيد اكيد
جهاد مقدسي
عميقه من المخابرات في تموز السنه الماضي
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الذي انا كنت اقرا
الورقه التي اعطيت يعترف بوجود سلاح
كيماوي وصلنا سنتين كل الكره الارضيه
بتقول السلاح الكيماوي امن لانه من النظام
ولو كان في ايدي العصابات المسلحه يتدخل
العالم كله لنزع هذا السلاح من الكتائب
العصابات المسلحه انا بدي افترض عصابات ضد
الخطه لم اذا استمر المجرمون بقصر الوضع
بعد ال بعد الضرب
ثانيا خلينا نرجع لجنه التحقيق العربيه
المراقبين العرب يوم الايجابي ما كانوا عم
بيقولوا سحبوا الاليات وطلعوا كل
المراقبين صور الدبابات كيف من خبايا
بالزواريب عندما اتت المراقبون الدوليون
ترتكب بوجود المراقبين البلدات ال حوله
والكبيره
النظام يقول العالم لا يصدق مادام موجودين
يعني هذا النظام الفاجر لا لك شو اللي صار
بعد كلام اوباما عن الخط الاحمر نظام ضرب
الناس ستين مره هم متوقع
هل يعقل ان يحرج حلفائه في ايران وروسيا
ويضعهم في هذا المازق
رئيس الاركان الامريكي منجيب عم بيقول لن
نقف مع المعارضه لان مصالح المعارضه
تتعارض مع مصالح امريكا
وهم عرفوا انهم استطاعوا ضربتين ضربه بعد
كلام اوباما ولم يتدخل يضربوا يضربونا
بصواريخ سكود والعالم لا يدخل يعني مثل ما
قال الشيخ السكوت هو الموت الرحيم ماذا
يختلف الموضوع بس علي الكيماوي
انا ما اريد ان اقوله بكل وضوح كان عليهم
في اللحظه الاولى ان يمسك لجنه التحقيق
نقطه
تركوا لجنه التحقيق في خمس
تقول سوريا خمسه اشهر
هناك سبب الان جاءت انه كانت موجوده بعد
اتهام المعارضه الى ان نطلق عليها الرصاص
قبل كان المفروض يسحبوا
اثبتنا العالم كله يعرف الجيش الكيماوي
الا اذا كانت من قناه الجزيره
يمكن
يمكن السعوديه
السعوديه
يعني من من يكتب هذا الكلام هذا الكلام هو
يعرف تماما انه تورط
يعني ما حدث في العالم
جابوا براميل قطريه المانيه برنامج صناعه
في السعوديه صور 11
عليه
تعليق في نقطه مهمه انت قلت
يعني من الغباء بما معناه او من غير
الممكن ان يقدم النظام على استخدام
الكيماوي طبعا المفتشون موجودين صح ولا لا
مسائل
الرجل يقول لها
معظم المجازر التي حدثت في سوريا حدثت
عندما كان المحققون او
فرق التفتيش موجوده الامر الاخر عندما
استشهد رئيس وزراء لبنان رفيق الحريري كل
الناس كل الناس التهمت سوريا بعض الناس
اتهم وسوريا فقالت سوريا يومها انه هل
يعقل ان ن تورط نحن في هذا الوضع الماساوي
نحن وضعنا سيء جدا في لبنان ولا يمكن ان
نقدم على كارثه مثل هذه ولا خطا مثل هذه
والجميع قال يعني هل السوريين يطلق النار
على رجل يقتل الحريري
دارت الايام
لن نرى ان بشار الاسد هو الذي قتل الحريري
في مشكله دارت الايام
ل توجه اصابع الاتهام الى حزب الله
والنظام السوري هو الذي قتل الحريري قتل
الحريري في وقت حرج جدا يقوم بضرب ال كما
تحال جدا هكذا يقولون
هذه القصه وهذه يعني يعني هو تكلم عن عن
الفرقه التحقيق الدوليه من الامم المتحده
التي اتت الى سوريا بعد خمسه اشهر تمام
طالبت الحكومه السوريه في اذار مارس
الماضي ان تاتي
موجوده
يمنعوها لكن
الامم المتحده سمتها فرق تفتيش
التفتيش ممنوعه تفتيش يعني ان هذه الفرق
تستطيع الدخول الى اي موقع عسكري الى اي
دائره حكوميه الى اي مكان سوريا طلبت
التحقيق في ضرب الكيماوي في خان العسل و
منطقتين اثنين يعني لا فكان الاختلاف على
كلمه التحقيق والتفتيش وعندما وافقت الامم
المتحده على التخطيط رحب بهذه الفئه بهذه
المجموعه واتت الى سوريا هذا من ناحيه
اعطيني
بشرط ان لا تقول من الفاعل
اذن نظام بقول استخدم الكبار تقول وامريكا
بتقول اسرائيل
عليها
كيف تفسر كيف تفسر
ان الكثير من مؤيدي النظام وخاصه في السته
وثمانين احتفلوا واطلقوا الرصاص ووزعوا
الحلوه فيه وين في البرامج احتفالا
بالكيماوي الذي استشهد استشاط تلبيه لرغبه
احدى الفجر
مستشفى مستشار اسماء الاسد مستشار اسماء
الاسد اى مردم بك
المقرر بالرئاسه الجمهوريه وصديق زوجه
الرئيس ومستشارها في شؤون المشتريات
والديكور وكل الناس بتعرف كتب على الفيس
بوك هذا ما كتبه بالضبط
شو الكيماوي هذا هذا هو هلا الكيماوي حلم
المزيد مستشار اسماء الاسد يحتفل عن فيس
بوك وبتجي بتقول
الكيماوي اذا اذا يعني انا قرات مقالات
كثيره خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه اه في في
اوروبا ويقولون ان سوريا لديها كما وي اه
الكيماوي ان وجد في سوريا هو اه سلاح
للسلاح النووي في اسرائيل هذا ما
اسرائيليه انا ما بعرف
اسرائيل ضربه اسرائيل النووي
نحنا عم نقول
المشكله يعني يعطوا يعني
نحن
يعني نقطه
كيف ترد على هذا الكلام يقول لك من يعني
لماذا اه اه نبني احكامنا على كلام قيل
هنا وهناك نا توزعوا حلوه وناس احتفلوا
الاعلام اسبوع في الدنيا يعني هل ممكن هذا
الرجل لم يقل هذا الكلام
دقيقه يعني بال بال بال بالامس كان هناك
صوره صوره لسوريا امراه سمينه وصوره
لسوريا امراه نحيفه موجوده في احدى ال ال
ال ال شو اسمه المواقع المؤيده للنظام انه
قبل سته عشر مليون سوري يروح او ستين
داهيه سوريا هيك احلى هذا الكلام يعني هل
يمكن ان نصدقه نحن
انا الكيماوي احد الشهر
شريف شحاده قال له المكشوف قتلونا بجبل
الاكراد بدنا اياها
موجوده قناه العربيه يعني يعني اعترف ما
اعترف الكيماوي اعترف بالقتل وهم بالبدايه
لم ينجروا القتل واستمروا في القتل لم
يتوقف اطلاق الصواريخ
على الغوطه ولا لحظه يعني لو ما كانوا مش
المائه انا قلت له فرصه ل اسعاف الناس
يعني انا بدي افترض عصابات مسلحه قتلت
تبادل الناس ما من حقهم يكون في وقف اطلاق
النار تعالجوا دوله يقصد هدول الناس
مجرمين هذا ليس شعبه بس انا بدي اقول كلمه
يعني اليوم كان في شيء خطير جدا قال وليد
المعلم كلام طائفي بغيت
الغوطه بندافع عن جرمانا ونضرب جوبر يدافع
عن القصه المسيحيه
يعني انا اه يعني لماذا جرم انا مش مباشره
او
بغداد او او هذا يفسر لماذا اقدم من نظام
يوم ضرب الكيماوي على تفجير السياره في
القصه هذا الكلام الطائفي البغيض خليني
قول الكلمتين لانديه السيدات
والله عندنا معلومات سوف يضربون يكون
بالكيماوي بالسويد لكي يتهموا القاعده
وجبهه النصره والاسلاميه المتشددين
واحد موجوده
وفي الناصر شو شو
مدير المخابرات العسكريه بالمنطقه
الجنوبيه
والله اذا صارت
المخابرات العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
اليوم على ان لا توجه بخطاب الراي العام
الامريكي وتحدث عن المسيحيين وعن الدروس
مثل ما قال
بدون مقاطعه خلينا خلينا خلينا
وانت بموضوع تحكي مشاكل
طيب هناك كلام اليوم عن انه مناطق
الاقليات قد تتعرض لضربات كيماويه
وخاصه المناطق المسيحيه هو تحدث عن ما
بعرف شو الاسماء ما تعرف اللي جبتها انت
وفريق الناصر العقيد رئيس فرع الامن
العسكري في المنطقه الجنوبيه
السؤال المطروح هو هذه الاتهامات طيب ماذا
تقول لهم يقول لك انه النظام لا يتورع عن
ضرب مناطق الاقليات بالكيماوي
يعني اعتقد ان التدخل لحمايه الاقليات نحن
نتحدث عن مواطنه هم يتحدثون عن الاقليات
المشكله بين البدو والسويدي
السويد والله
انا اغلب السويدي بدنا احنا من بيد السويد
وانما قبل ي يستلم السلطه
المراه
لانه
كيف لا تتوقع من هذا النظام ان يقدم علي
الكيماوي اذا لم يترك وسيله ال او
استخدمها مثلا استخدم البرامج اللي استخدم
سكوت ب استخدم الطائرات استخدم هلا توقفت
علي الكيماوي يعني الذي رفع شعار الاسد او
نحرق البلد ممكن يسويها بخيتان قال البشير
قال له يا حبيبي اذا انتم مفكرين ب سقطوا
الاسد هي مستعدين يقتلون صف الشعب السوري
اللي بيقول هذا الكلام يعني يعني
يعني مصرين انه المجموعات الثانيه انه
الكيماوي موجود عندها عند الدوله في سوريا
الجيش
كما في خمسه في سبعه وعشرين
الحكومه التركيه وليس نحن على مجموعه
تتعلق عشر شخص من جبهه النصره في منطقه او
مرسين بتركيا
اه اثناء التحقيق بتفجيرات في حداش خمسه
[موسيقى]
انت تقول انه المجموعات الارهابيه هي التي
يمكن ان
يعني
البعض يقول البعض
وانت منهم انه النظام
المعطيات اللي استخدمها الطرف الاخر طيب
البعض لا تاخذ مني انا مش
البعض يقول انه يا سيدي نحن نتفق مع انه
الارهابيون هم الذين ضربوا الكيماوي وهم
الذين يستخدمون وهم الذين دمروا وهم الذين
هذا الجيش العربي السوري سنتين ما قدر لها
الارهابيين الدوله التي لا تستطيع منع
الارهابيين من ادخال الكيماوي الى بلدها
لقتل شعبها هذه بلد هذه دوله فاشله وبدا
غرب بالسلام هكذا يقولون
ولهذا القضاء كنت روح اللي عند الحكومه
القطريه ان اوقفوا المعونات او
خلينا نتفق مع انه
تعمل طيب اليست مسؤوليه النظام ان يحمي
شعبه من الكيماوي كيف دخل الكيماوي الى
الغوطه كيف دخل الكيماوي الى جانب القصر
الجمهوري هذا النظام الذي يحمي شعبه ويخلي
اللي عنده القصر الجمهوري هذا النظام طيب
كيف صنع هذا المواد السامه عن طريق ريح
السلطه كتيبه
بمواد سامي تركي
تركيا وعرضت على الدوليه
في البدايه قبل اربعه عارضوا هذه المواد
السامه من شركات تركيه وارض على كثير بقتل
الامامين ان تشاهدها
طيب لماذا لماذا لا نقول انه الكلام انت
تكذب النظام السوري النظام السوري كاذب
النظام السوري لا يمكن ان تصدقوا وكما قال
قلتها اكثر من مره لا يمكن ان تصدق حتى في
درجات الحراره فكيف نصدق النظام السوري
ولا نصدق امريكا والاقمار الصناعيه وكذا
وكذا طيب البعض يقول لك ايضا امريكا كذبت
في العراق وادعت ان هناك اسلحه دمار شامل
في العراق وضرب العراق ودمر العراق ولم
يكن هناك اسلحه دمار شامل لماذا تريدون
تدمير سوريا لماذا تستعدون الناس على
سوريا لماذا تريدون ان تدمر هذا الوطن
الجميل اه ب ب تحت حجج وهي ايضا كما يقول
الاسرائيليه اولا بالنسبه للاسرائيليين
انت سمعت والعالم كله سمع السيد ايام
عندما سؤل لماذا تسمحون لقوات بشار
للدبابات بشار للطيران بشار ان يدخل مناطق
منزوعه السلاح كان الجواب على الحدود
الاسرائيليه ما بيسمحوا لنا نسمح لهم
واحده
بالتالي واحده كل الكره الارضيه بتقول ان
الخوف هو من الوصول الكيماوي الى العصابات
المسلحه
ولو كان
لا شفت فرق الكوماندوس لازال فورا لا تضر
بالجيش الحر ويرجع ثانيه يعني عم نحكي عن
اثنين وستين ضربه عم نحكي بدمشق بالغوطتين
عشره ضربه هل تملك المعارضه رحله بس كل
منها لا يعرفه هناك الان تسجيلات لضباط
الجيش السوري وقت حدوث الضربه هناك اقمار
صناعيه رصد اطلاق الصواريخ من جبل قاسيون
الى الروتين من مطار الى
باختصار
لكن كان
يكون فيها جوه كيماوي بيروح الناس هؤلاء
مجرمون انا بدي اسالك ما يقدر بالناس يعني
ما هو الفرق بين
يعني عندما تطلق صاروخ
خمسمائه متر ماذا يعني ذلك هادول اللي
خايفين عن سوريا الجميله اللي دمر مليون
وسبعمائه الف
سبعمائه
يعني بهذه الحاله اللجوء الى الكيماوي
دليل ياس وعجز وانهيار الجيش السوري هذا
الله انه بعد الكيماوي
لا لا انا بدي اسالك انه لجوء النظام
للكيماوي
محاصره يستطيع الدخول
حقيقه انا اسالك بالاتجاه الاخر طيب الا
تعتقد ان هناك تناقضا في خطاب النظام
السوري قبل ايام قال الرئيس الاسد بالحرف
الواحد ان النظام لا يمكن ان يضرب الغوطه
بالكيماوي لانها تحت سيطرته من قال هذا
الكلام الرئيس الاسد لاسيا ماشي يقول لك
اه ال ال الطب واليوم وزير الخارجيه
المعلم يقول عكس الكلام تماما قال يا
جماعه لا يمكن للجيش السوري اخفاء اثار
الكيماوي لان الغوطه تحت سيطره الارهابيين
وهذا اليوم
موجوده
المجموعات المجموعات
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا وما
يتبعها من السعوديه
عندما كلمه وزير الخارجيه السوري وليد
المعلم
سته وثلاثين سته وثلاثين ساعه
في مناطق السوري
وانا
عندي ضمانات جميع جميع ال ال ال مسلحين من
كتائب مختلفه
مهمه جدا ومهم جدا كل من يدعو الى ضرب
بلده
هذا الكلام قال اليوم
وانا
اليوم السيد المعلم وزير الخارجيه
وقال ان اي اعتداء على سوريا سيكون في
صالح اسرائيل
الشعب السوري يسال بعد
انه اي اعتداء على سوريا الان اللي هو
يعني يضر بلده بيكون اه يكون لصالح
اسرائيل الناس تسال المعلم يا سياده
المعلم الم يكن الدمار الهائل الذي احدثه
النظام في سوريا يصب في مصلحه اسرائيل
ايضا اليس زج الجيش في معارك داخليه مدمره
في مصلحه اسرائيل يا معلم اليس تبديد
الترسانه السوريه على الداخل السوري في
مصلحه اسرائيل يا ايها المعلم اليس
استشهاد اكثر من مائه الف جندي و ضابط
سوري حسب شريف الشهاده في معارك ضد الشعب
في مصلحه اسرائيل ايها المعلم الحقيقه هذا
ليس تدمير البنيه التحتيه وعشرات المدن
والقرى يصب في مصلحه اسرائيل ايها المعلم
ماذا تريد اسرائيل اكثر من ان ترى اعدائها
يدمرون اوطانهم بانفسهم يا ايها المعلم
على الدوله السوريه
السيول السياسي المخابرات في الجيش العربي
اليوم بتغير شكرا خلينا نقول فرضه عن طريق
هؤلاء الوكلاء يعني هناك حرب في سوريا
هؤلاء يطلقون النار يصبحون العالم يخضعون
الروس
ياخذون ال ال ال ال ال فوا مع الى تركيا
ياخذون المحامي تركيا فافسدوا في سوريا
ماذا تريد الدوله ان تفعل
نفس نفس الكلام كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
يعني ايضا عندما تتهمون الدوله بكذا وهي
التي كذا وتستخدم كذا يا اخي قد تضطر
الدوله في في الكثير من الاحيان لحمايه
بلدها حتى لو استخدمت اسلحه محرمه
يا اخي البعض يقول حتى انت تقول انه مش
الجيش الحر عملها
والرجل يقول لك مش الجيش النظامي او الجيش
الوطني عملها
قد يكون هناك
قد يكون هناك طرف ثالث دخل على الخط
طيب لمصلحه من الان الضربه فيما حصل فيما
لو حصلت الضربات هل تحتاج سوريا لضرب الان
هل يحتاج الشعب السوري بعد كل هذا العداء
لضربه خارجيه يعني نزيد الدمار اهلا دكتور
بعد سنتين من سنتين
بعد كلامه وستين ضربه كيماويه لم تتدخل
امريكا
وصول السلاح للشعب السوري لو كانت امريكا
تريد اسقاط النظام اللي قدمنا كل خدماته
خلال اربعين سنه كما قال علي مملوك على
الاقل كانوا كانوا سمحوا لنا نحصلها
السلاح بالدول الشقيقه
سنتين ممنوع علينا انه
دمار شامل النا بان
البرامج
سلاح ال او استخدموا هذه الضربه اللي
سوريا
الاوباش اللي عم يضربوا الناس من قاسيون
عندما سياسيون وفي او باش اللي قتله الشعب
السوري مجلس الشعب السوري والامه العربيه
كلها
ليس حبا بامريكا ولكن يعني يعني يعني
برايك الشارع العربي الان سيبارك الضربه
الامريكيه
مبارك الضربه الامريكيه سيبلغ قد لا وغاب
خليني اسالك سؤال انت تعلم هذه هذه وصلتني
من ابو رياض
حقيقه ابو رياض الحلبي يقول لك هل يعقل ان
نشهد مظاهره ضد استخدام الكيماوي او ضد
استخدام النظام السوري للكيماوي في تل
ابيب في قلب تل ابيب مظاهره
ماوى ولا شهد مظاهره واحده في دمشق بعد
الحرب
اللي اخوتهم الناس بيشربوا بياخذوا
[موسيقى]
الرياض الحلبي قالوا ليش ليش ما ما ما ما
ما ما عملته مظاهره ضد الكيماوي قال بسبب
القبضه الامنيه الناس خايفه من القبض
الامني يسال الرجل اليس الشعب الذي يتعرض
ليس الشعب الذي يتعرض لضربه كيماويه ويخمد
ويسكت بسبب القبضه الامنيه كانت بيده من
نووي
وتنامي كمان احنا بالكيماوي وخارج من
القبضه الامنيه شو بتقول والرياض يا دكتور
انا
بيقولوا تمام بس انا بدي اقول كلمه هذا
الشعب والله ساني لو تعرف انا طلبه مني
تهريبها تركيا اتحاد حزام ناسف وفجر حتى
اذا حاول واغتصبوني يفجر نفسه
هذا هو النظام المجرم اللي حول الناس
العبيد
ولكن الشعب السلاح اللي اللي تحمل اثنين
سيطرت كيماوي والله الذي هذه ثلاثه وستين
ضربه هذا الشعب صار له النظام سته شهور
على حار صغيره المش ويتقدم النظام اخذ
الاقتصاد
الله اليوم على الطريق
اليوم
يا اخي في نقطه مهمه كيف ترد على الذين
يقولون ان الجماعات المسلحه الارهابيه
التكفيريين ال الكذا لجؤوا الى الكيماوي
لانه النظام اوشك على الانتصار في سوريا
وهم يريدون ان انظار العالم
الجمعه الاخيره الثلاثه
عناصر اليومين الطريق البري قواتهم خاصه
عنده المطار
ما باي شيء في معبر 1 ملعون انفاس النظام
يخوض معركته يريد الحفاظ على دمشق من خلال
ضرب الغوطه والا سيلجا الى خيار الدوليه
الطائفيه او بالاجابه الاكراد ولن تكون
هناك دوله طائفيه مره اخرى بيقول هو يتحدث
عن كليات هذا النظام المجرم يخاطب الدروز
يخاطب العالميين
تقول انه الاقليات عباره عن كبش فداء هو
يستخدمهم ونحن نقول شعب سوري واحد في
مواطنه ما في اقليات بس بقول اهلنا
بالساعه بها اللحظه اليوم يمكن
ضباط
عمليات الاخلاء عائلات الضباط
والله
عمليه هروب كبيره
الوقت هذا الكلام اليوم موجود باكثر من
وكاله انه سيارات هروب جماعي من دمشق
لكبار الضباط وعائلات وضباط وخاصه
العلويين
موجوده في الانترنيت ماذا تقول يعني
الخميس الماضي
يذهبوا الى
الدوله السوريه انتظرت
هناك مجموعات مسلحه هنا هناك قتال في
سوريا
النقطه بالاعلام يقولون ما يريدون
انا اتفق مع مديره انا
وظهر هذا
هذا هو
ماذا تقول الان ماذا تقول للذين
ماذا تقول الذين يحضرون لضرب سوريا الان
اه طبول الحرب تقرع في كل مكان والضربه
حسب ما حسب ما هو واضح قادمه ماذا تقول
لهم علينا الحرب اللي ضرب البنيه التحتيه
واذا فرضوا علينا الارض ان شاء الله نحن
سمعنا من الحكومه وهذا يعني انا ما الدوله
في السوريه وبين الجيش السوري هناك
ترتيبات هناك تجهيزات هناك
دافع عن سوريا
ماذا تقول انت الان وقبول طبول الحرب تقرع
ماذا تقول للشارع العربي ماذا تقول للذين
يقولون لا لضرب سوريا كل هذا الكلام بدي
اقول شغله عندما يطلع بشار الاسد من جهه
سيرها قواته في الشاهين
[موسيقى]
بس باختصار
سوريا تتحدث النظام يتحدى اي ضربه باختصار
سوريا ستبقى
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبق لنا ان نشكر
ضيفينا السيد السيد بسام جعاره نلتقي مساء
الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]